y
[Música]
el pleno del congreso de perú admitió la
moción de vacancia contra el presidente
martín vizcarra el mandatario es acusado
de incapacidad moral por haber
presuntamente pedido a sus asesores que
emitieran para ocultar un caso de
corrupción conocido como el caso richard
swing el mandatario había dicho ayer que
no renunciaría al cargo
[Música]
en un nuevo logro diplomático para la
administración de donaldson israelí para
alcanzar un acuerdo para la
normalización de sus relaciones
diplomáticas
esto mes después del pacto logrado con
emiratos árabes unidos- autoridades
palestinas así como el gobierno iraní
condenaron el acuerdo calificándolo de
traición
los incendios siguen desgastando la
costa oeste de eeuu donde ya se
registran por lo menos 24 muertos en los
estados de oregón washington y
california
la gobernadora de oregón donde un 10% de
la población del estado está bajo alerta
de evacuación aseguro que hay decenas de
desaparecidos y que el número de
víctimas podría aumentar
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 y roland
concurso saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en perú donde el congreso
aprobó la moción de vacancia es decir la
destitución contra el presidente martín
vizcarra con 65 votos a favor 36 en
contra y 24 abstenciones los
legisladores aprobaron que se inicia el
proceso contra el jefe de estado el
presidente vizcarra es acusado de pedir
a sus asesores que mintieran en una
investigación para parlamentaria sobre
la contratación de un cantante para
analizar la crisis política en perú
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal en
lima francisco zacarías francisco muy
buena noche le pido por favor que nos
explica entonces los detalles del
llamado caso richard swing que salpica
al presidente y por qué generó esta
nueva crisis política en el país
buenas noches richard swing o mejor
dicho richard cisneros es un cantante
desconocido en perú que se volvió
mediático luego de las denuncias de
algunos medios locales que lo
responsabilizaban de haber sido
favorecido con contratos del ministerio
de cultura- por 50 mil dólares gracias a
su cercanía con el presidente de martín
vizcarra el mandatario en las
investigaciones preliminares negó haber
favorecido a richard swing con los
contratos y mucho menos haberse reunido
con él pero en las grabaciones dadas a
conocer en el parlamento se escucha la
voz del mandatario indicándole a sus
colaboradores cómo arreglar el registro
de visitas y cuáles las palabras que
debe dar ante la fiscalía para muchos
congresistas esto es obstrucción a la
justicia y se habrían incurrido en
delito también de manipulación de
testigos por eso es que ellos consideran
que el presidente ha incurrido en
incapacidad moral y que le habría
mentido a los peruanos y por eso ya
carecería de credibilidad y es por eso
que hoy fue aprobada
admitida a debate la moción de
destitución o vacancia presidencial
ahora francisco le pregunto cuáles son
los siguientes pasos en este proceso
contra el presidente de íscar y cuáles
son los escenarios posibles
precisamente acaba de culminar la sesión
del parlamento peruano el presidente de
martín vizcarra va a tener un plazo de 3
a 10 días para presentarse en el
parlamento con su abogado
algunos legisladores están diciendo que
la cita podría ser este viernes 18 de
septiembre en la cual el abogado de
vizcarra va a exponer todos los
argumentos de acuerdo a la constitución
luego de oír los alegatos el congreso
tendría que ejecutar la votación de
dicen que ya tienen alrededor de 87
votos y luego de esto el presidente del
congreso el actual presidente del
congreso miguel merino sería investido
como presidente del perú estaría
facultado de acuerdo a la constitución
de tener un gobierno de transición por
10 meses y convocar a un nuevo proceso
de elecciones vamos a ver entonces qué
ocurre en perú francisco estamos muy
pendientes lo que ocurre en lima gracias
por la información que tengo usted de
una muy buena noche cambiamos ahora el
tema en colombia la cifra de fallecidos
en las violentas jornadas de protesta
contra la brutalidad policial asensio
este
reza 13 con las muertes de tres
ciudadanos más en bogotá la capital del
país
las protestas que hoy ya registran
nuevos desmanes iniciaron tras la muerte
de javier ordóñez el miércoles luego de
ser violentamente sometido por oficiales
que le aplicaron múltiples descargas
eléctricas la investigación reveló este
viernes que ordóñez habría muerto como
consecuencia de un golpe con un objeto
contundente en la cabeza cuando se
encontraba detenido una estación
policial en un intento por calmar los
ánimos o cuando se espera una tercera
jornada de protestas como la que ya
estamos viendo en bogotá la policía
pidió perdón tanto a la familia de la
víctima como al pueblo colombiano
creo que de acuerdo a lo que se viene
manejando a lo que todos vimos el vídeo
se constituye en un actuar que no es
propio de los policías de colombia los
policías de colombia estamos para
proteger la vida honra y bienes de todos
los ciudadanos por eso hoy le pedimos y
como director encargado la policía
nacional perdón a su familia perdón a
sus amigos perdón a todos los ciudadanos
a todos los colombianos
en eeuu el presidente de donald trump
anunció la normalización de relaciones
entre pares e israel- calificándolo como
un logro histórico poco menos un mes
después de un pacto similar alcanzado
con emiratos árabes unidos los dos
países existen estar listos para abrir
embajadas organizar vuelos directos y
cooperar en varios sectores los
palestinos temen que los acercamientos
los dejen cada vez más aislados
otro acuerdo entre rivales históricos
bahrein acuerdo la normalización de sus
relaciones con israel según lo anunciado
por el presidente de eeuu donald trump
se intercambiarán embajadas y
embajadores iniciarán vuelos directos
entre sus países y pondrán en marcha
iniciativas de cooperación en una amplia
gama de sectores entre ellos la salud
los negocios la tecnología la educación
la seguridad y la agricultura
bahréin decidió seguir los pasos de su
vecino emiratos árabes unidos quien
firmó un acuerdo similar hace apenas 29
días hasta ahora israel sólo había
llegado a dos tratados de paz con países
árabes
egipto en 1979 y jordania en 1994 el
primer ministro israelí afirmó que más
países árabes seguirían el ejemplo
21 esta es una nueva era de paz paz por
paz economía por economía hemos
invertido en la paz durante muchos años
y ahora la paz de invertir en nosotros
conducirá inversiones muy grandes en la
economía israelí y eso es muy importante
palestinos que ven el apoyo árabe como
crucial para resistir a la ocupación
israelí rechazaron el plan la
organización yihadista hamás que
controla la franja de gaza dijo que el
acuerdo era un peligro para la causa
palestina
la doble del bajar en bahrein después de
los emiratos se une al camino de la
normalización con el régimen sionista'
convirtiéndolos en un socio en la
agresión con nuestro pueblo palestino
porque significa que aceptan el trato
del siglo que trump anuncios o de evans
andy el com a la vida el enemigo
histórico de israel irán también
denunció la normalización el gobierno de
trump ha hecho una prioridad la
aplicación de sanciones drásticas y
presión diplomática sobre la república
islámica y tras el anuncio del viernes
el mandatario de eeuu predijo que habría
un desarrollo muy positivo en el
enfrentamiento con teherán
se cumplen seis meses desde que el brote
de kobe 19 fue declarado como pandemia
por parte de la organización mundial de
la salud el virus que se originó en
china ha dejado de momento más de 28
millones de contagiados y 900 10.000
fallecidos para analizar la situación
sanitaria por cuenta de esta pandemia
quiero saludar en este momento a roberto
debagg él es médico infectólogo
vicepresidente de la sociedad de
latinoamericana de infectología
pediátrica doctor de bach buenas noches
gracias por estar con nosotros en france
24 me preguntó entonces qué podemos
esperar ya son 6 meses desde el que kobe
19 cambió por completo la realidad de
millones de personas sobre una vacuna
podrá devolvernos la normalidad a la que
estábamos acostumbrados bueno gracias
por la invitación si sin ninguna duda la
vacuna va a hacer parte de la solución
porque creemos todos los gobernantes del
mundo científico que pasa por dos
situaciones por el de atencia miento
social la utilización de tapabocas
barbijos o cubrebocas y la aparición de
una vacuna que sea eficaz y sea segura
sobre todo ahora qué pasará luego
de la pandemia cuales cree que serán los
cambios fundamentales que vamos a vivir
además estamos viendo una experiencia
traumática como esta y que dejará en la
sociedad
bueno primero estamos viviendo los
aspectos adversos de las 40 y las
prolongadas y de convivir con un virus
que está ganando la batalla porque más
de 20 millones de personas se han
contagiado de casi un millón de personas
han muerto luego de este momento
pandémico sin ninguna duda los efectos
adversos tienen que ser recuperados
tiene que ser recuperados por ejemplo la
vacunación infantil se sabe que por
ejemplo las américas en latinoamérica
más de 2 millones de niños en los
primeros meses durante 2 meses pandémica
no han recibido vacunas donde aumenta
donde va a aumentar el cáncer y sus
complicaciones producto de los retrasos
en los diagnóstico o sea vamos a tener
en los próximos pasos es la recuperación
de todas las epidemias ocultas que
produce el coronavirus ahora doctor para
cuando a lo mejor podemos esperar esta
tan deseada vacuna que además ya y
astrazéneca ipauss o de momento entonces
el desarrollo de esta vacuna por una un
acontecimiento adverso en una paciente
bueno el acontecimientos todavía no se
conoce si este siesta mielitis
transversa en una persona voluntaria de
la investigación en inglaterra fue
debida a la vacuna o fue un evento
relacionado como puede pasar con alguna
enfermedad que ocurra en los en los
voluntarios esto todavía no lo sabemos
lo que creemos que no se están
produciendo el paro no se está
produciendo la cancelación de estudios
todo lo contrario y se espera que para
el 2021 sobre todo el primer semestre
del 2021 se disponga de vacunas en la
mayoría de los países del mundo para la
vacunación de las personas prioritarias
que van a ser los trabajadores de salud
y los mayores de 60 años cuando
enfermedades existentes doctor de vacas
gracias por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros en france 24 feliz resto de
noche el presidente donald trump y su
rival demócrata yo va a iniciar en una
pausa en sus respectivas campañas
electorales para honrar a casi 3.000
víctimas fatales que dejaron los ataques
del 11 de septiembre hace 19 años bailén
participó en un solemne en una solemne
ceremonia conmemorativa
en nueva york' en el llamado con un
civil donde se cruzó con el
vicepresidente mike pence por su parte
donald trump comenzó el día en
shanksville en pensilvania donde se
estrelló el vuelo 93 que había sido
secuestrado y que se dirigía
presuntamente al capitolio baiden visitó
de la misma zona horas más tarde
nadie ni versión de éste
hace 19 años en este día a esta misma
hora y en este mismo lugar 40 hombres y
mujeres valientes triunfaron sobre el
terror y dieron sus vidas en defensa de
nuestra nación sus nombres y sus
historias están para siempre escritas en
la eterna lista de héroes
estadounidenses hoy rendimos tributo su
sacrificio y profundamente lamentamos la
cerca de tres mil almas hermosas que nos
fueron arrebatadas el 11 de septiembre
de 2001
en más de 100 focos de incendios
continúan activos devastando la costa
oeste de eeuu provocando la muerte de
por lo menos 24 personas y generando la
peor calidad del aire registrada en los
estados de california washington y
oregón en este último cerca de medio
millón de personas un 10% de la
población del estado se encuentra bajo
alerta de evacuación aún hay decenas de
desaparecidos
el informe de valentina torre sánchez
reducidas las cenizas y escombros así se
ven varias localidades del sur del
estado de oregon en eeuu tras la
devastación causada por el fuego
los bomberos continúan luchando para
controlar las conflagraciones que
mantuvieron su intensidad a causa de los
fuertes vientos en los últimos días sin
embargo las condiciones climáticas están
mejorando cuídense prevemos aire más
fresco y humedad en los próximos días lo
cual es una muy buena noticia sin
embargo los bomberos continúan
trabajando día y noche para salvar vidas
y propiedades de la destrucción se han
quemado más de 4000 kilómetros cuadrados
en este momento la calidad del aire es
la peor del mundo y debido a estos
incendios
jurídics faiers las autoridades
informaron que hay docenas de personas
desaparecidas y el número de fallecidos
posiblemente aumentará los fuegos se
acercan a los suburbios de portland la
mayor ciudad del estado donde ordenaron
el estado de emergencia en california
casi 4.000 hogares han sido destruidos y
más de 68 mil personas han recibido la
orden de evacuar al visitar una de las
zonas más afectadas el gobernador del
estado arremetió contra quienes niegan
la gravedad del cambio climático otro
pedir es hacer el debate sobre el cambio
climático sólo vengan al estado de
california observen
con sus propios ojos no es un debate
intelectual ni siquiera es debatible
se estima que el área consumida en la
costa oeste de eeuu es equivalente al
tamaño del estado de nueva jersey que
tiene unos 22.500 kilómetros cuadrados
lamentable la mítica banda de rock the
rolling song se convirtió en la primera
encabezar las listas de reino unido en
seis décadas distintas el grupo alcanzó
el hito al llegar de nuevo al número uno
este viernes la banda subió directamente
al primer lugar por una versión
remasterizada de su álbum good hit sub
que se lanzó originalmente en 1973
ah
muerte
[Música]
con música despedimos el informativo
continúe con nosotros buena noche
[Música]